[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is
coming home
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
grocery bags
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i can save up to retirement
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dot com
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
for people for for people listening on
audio oh no my mic is on it is on yeah i
just have the face shield on is this i'm
going to okay you know what i'm taking
this away
i'm going to take this face shield off
is that better look even joe lewis
doesn't like it he's already left this
is a horrible
uh
well this is the first show back yeah
this is the first show back and by the
way everyone if you are watching we are
temporarily unbanned from youtube if you
miss this show it's monday through
thursday i know we didn't do a show
yesterday i'll explain why uh you can
always watch us on rumble right
rumble.com smash that over there
tim the tool man is working on tricaster
today uh it's on rumble it's on mug club
by the way you enter in the promo code
lwc returns to get 20 off an annual
subscription for mug club and you know
hold on before i move on can you can you
show them what we got here this this
this whole setup can we just i i tested
positive for the
omni core virus yeah but it was it was
like it was days ago and i haven't had
symptoms for a long time well according
so that's that's a good question you
posted something yesterday but you
actually had symptoms last week about
the same time i did and we're both cdc
cleared now yes we're both seeing any of
you jerks out there trying to make a
thing yeah you're six days in or else i
wouldn't be here right yeah exactly
right but you're not immune compromise
you're just you know the bmi isn't
perfect hey guys can we just get rid of
it can we get rid of this plexiglas i
feel like someone's going to get hip
checked into the but
do i have permission to have consent i
think so all right hold on yes you're
fine
you are in cdc guidelines you're healthy
you're good today well they changed it
because the science changed so hey yes
the science changed and you can take joe
lewis out where it was all the rules
we'll never
we will never know hey you know what at
least you still have your country
so
do you remember do you remember by the
way my question of the day and i want
you to comment below the best thing you
can do here while we're back on youtube
okay is smash the like button okay right
now if you're on youtube do it you can
comment too well all right here i'll do
this first comment comment comment below
little rusty is do you remember when uh
gain of function was considered a
conspiracy theory hey do you remember
when we discussed gain of function here
on youtube and we were fact checked
we were fact checked and they checked in
the fact check check
and now uh we have some new leaked
documents where it's it's very clear i
mean it's there's a there's a building
case i don't even think that fauci
denies it and the next best thing you
can do is smash that like button right
now on youtube everyone watching yeah
smash the like button okay commenting is
the most important thing you can do for
the algorithm because uh youtube doesn't
if you type in stephen crowd or abortion
change my mind you find an old pbs video
really not the millions of play videos i
have no idea it used to be the case they
change it every day the point is
everything sucks but we're going to be
talking about kazakhstan
and russia we're going to be fact
checking the supreme court today uh
we're going to be talking about what's
going on in new york and we're going to
be talking about the voter suppression
law um which is in case i don't know if
you know this if you go to buy uh buy a
pack at chesterfield at the 7-eleven
yeah you're voter suppressed really yeah
oh man yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what
pressure is this it's well it's it's
2022 but they still have the right to
oppress those with melanin by uh having
the gall to ask for uh identification ah
or something that requires you be of age
so we're going to talk about all that
for chesterfields yes for chester fields
one out of ten doctors recommend
recommends chesterfield a nice smooth
pull the other nine recommend
parliaments yes
so before we get into all of that uh i'm
glad to introduce uh the people who are
here i'm really glad to be back with you
of course gerald a is here how are you
sir i am doing well i get my natural
immunity baby yeah well i had natural
immunity but the omicron evades uh well
it obviously evades vaccine immunity
well come on uh and then uh you know
natural immunity pretty much everyone i
know who already had the uh the the
covid who got the uh omni court just has
a mild cold yeah that's pretty much what
it was i was down for a day and that was
it yeah well that's because i kicked you
in the nuts well that was that was not
nice well yeah how are you doing i'm
doing it fine yeah horrible break but
i'll discuss that later but it has
nothing to do with it this actually the
omni core virus was a welcome respite
welcome respite from my break uh but the
the little ones are great little ones
are fun little boy he just he he has
that toothless grin yeah where he looks
like an old uh he looks like a wilford
brimley diabetes commercial smiling
uh on tricaster quarterback garrett of
course is not he's going to be in here
with some sketches but we have tim
toolman there and uh one of my favorite
people i have the funniest man on his
feet he will be
in reading california civic auditorium
january 15th and january 16th at the
crest theater in sacramento california
dave linda how are you sir ahoy
i'm good how about you
uh my son got this for me for christmas
because i'm a real potty mouth is that
what he did yeah
i'm surprised you're trying to wash your
mouth out with soap he did i told you
not to use the life boy yes and i wore
an omnicore shirt for you very nice oh
celebrate your illness yes the former
illness
i don't want anybody to get all goofy
yeah this weekend i'll be in writing
pens uh reading california there's so
many readings yeah i know right in
california and uh the crest theater but
reading is actually the state there is
trying to get me i think banned because
it went from 1500 seats to where they
would only allow a thousand yeah without
having to you know show a test or get
vaccinated and all that stuff right then
they just lowered it to 500 last night
so there's only a few tickets left
because they said i think they're trying
to get it so i don't go
because i'm uh on a republican show yes
this isn't really a republican show it's
a conservative show it's more of a
conservative show i just have it's a
general problem with authority show yeah
pretty much and that's the problem right
so i'm sure there'll be protests some
blue hairs screaming at me here's the
thing guys
with a cement milkshake if i'm lucky
yeah well you know what thank god you
know what count your lucky stars that
it's not acid that's true you could be a
lady in saudi arabia who tried to drive
stick and the next thing you know you
have a face like katie holmes well
that's true but
nobody wants that i mean if she was able
to drive it it probably would have ended
up that way yeah
wrapped around a tree oh did you punish
it for driving no she used the wrong
turn signal
that's why we have lots
stupid yes oh hey do you have learner's
permit i joke you can't learn
barrier to her head throw rocks let her
son go first now oh
geez i want your boy
who am i kidding i want all the boys yay
youtube glad we're back so
um
we have so much to get to today and uh
uh we also have a a tribute to uh bob
saget uh later on mug club for people
who are not mug club members we have an
extra show this friday for mug club
members because i know we missed one
yesterday where we're just going to be
taking some of your chats answering your
questions and soon enough dave and i
will watch a steven seagal film no yes
that's true yeah oh wow was the
beautiful one we watched above the law
uh no no no no above the law was the
original this is beyond the law this is
beyond the law possibly the worst movie
ever then there's the there's a then it
becomes um skirting the law and then the
final one is total disregard for the law
yes yeah
and then the last one is common decency
what is that what is it so uh before we
move on to everything else uh that we
have to talk to uh talk about today and
you're gonna be the one talking about
kazakhstan and russia okay i don't care
i've never heard of either i wish we
just listened to general patton and just
wiped out the russians after world war
ii
it was the time to do it it was the time
to do it you were gonna do it
it was the killing season so uh but
before that a german man named hans
peter etzold of course he is
launched a campaign for sheep uh to
arrange themselves
in the shape of
and i don't i think this is to raise
awareness but let's listen to him in his
funny voice that shouldn't be allowed to
be spoken anymore i feel like we should
have actually just uh converted them to
christianity and made them speak english
after world war ii for some reason they
still get to be a country
so we tried to arrange sheep in the
shape of a syringe here we go
[Music]
argument
[Music]
oh yeah they're in the shape of the
syringe of the growth hormone that'll be
put in their ass so that they can grow
wool faster he gets some geese to be
courtney loves arm yes
oh my god some ducks to become a knife
that was put in elliot smith's chest i
just i find can we play that again from
the just from the beginning just because
i want to i'm going to fact check this
really quickly all right
pause
no for people who are listening on audio
who's he's saying in germany is this
ship of really popular visit people
that's not even a true premise
what people in other words the re
someone said hey uh hans why are you
making the why are you making this ship
into a syringe i don't under is it's a
message about the vaccination about the
booster well first and foremost
first and foremost sheep as you well
know are very popular
there's this year's hoverboard
isn't it
a sheep in the shape of a syringe that's
pretty anti-vaxx if i've ever seen it
yeah you know that's what i would think
yes you would assume is that what he's
going for yeah i don't know i don't
understand and then there's just one
sheep dog who's dressed like nigel
farage you're like oh i get it i see
what he's doing
this backfired horribly
i don't know how i didn't see how this
could backfire considering sheep was so
popular visit people can you imagine the
stuff you could get done with your life
if you have the ability to arrange sheep
into a syringe like how much time did
that take and how drugged were those
sheep oh very oh my god all i had to do
was give them food in the right place
and they would go to it then i'm worried
and i can sleep i feel like i shake
syringes with my sheep
i feel that guy likes to jab his sheep
yes yes and i don't let my women drive
hello youtube
so
uh this is something before we move on
to what's happening here today can i can
i may i take a moment you may if you
have to drink from the toilet the entire
time it's going to be very distracting
it's not that distracting but we're
going to have people in mug clubs who
are asking us to sell a toilet mug
what's wrong with that we can put louder
with crowder right on here
it's very apropos you know what
we can put the ben shapiro show i'll
donate oh there we go yeah you know
let's do a bunch of hiroshima mugs yes
yeah but make it talk like a pee-wee's
playhouse like well actually the fact is
your stool is irregular and i would
recommend sending you a lap you suck
toiletty
i was gonna just drink from the mug but
installer took a shot on it
so
um
let me go this happened last week and i
wasn't here for uh reasons that uh i
won't get into right now it wasn't the
omicron omicron yet was you know
yesterday wasn't part uh but uh
last week this happened and the media uh
got uh as barack obama would say all wee
weed up yeah yeah he's about as accurate
with wee wheat up as that german man is
with the popularity of sheep
bronwell i was like oh no my mom always
just said don't get all wee-weed up and
people like is that a real thing yeah
it's the thing my mom everyone used to
say it uh in in kenya i mean hawaii and
then uh
when the guys are saying first yeah yeah
of course yeah they all get vived up and
sheep are popular with the people that's
they're the people's sheep who get
weaved up
so you don't have a sheep blind spot
stephen no i don't have a sheep blind
spot every now and then i hit a sheep in
my blind spot it's like well you know i
shouldn't been there
it's true accelerate defensive driving
whenever i see a sheep crossing i a gun
it yeah well they're bad drivers yes
my lord oh my was that the joke about
the woman because because my wife's a
goat i make a sweater right there in the
street that's right and i'm right were
you fondling your sweater i was not
fondling my sweater these cheap suits
that's it with cheap suits comment below
what's that reference
okay
so this happened with supreme court when
they had this whole meeting uh on uh on
the uh the omicron omnicore you screwed
me up with that oh sure
so and like i said we're talking about
osha and they were talking about the
authority and what authority they have
uh just to let you know um very little
now
that's not what the activist judges
think
and people were getting mad about
something that gorsuch said which we're
going to get to yeah trying to fact
check i'm saying can you believe this
guy's a supreme court justice okay i'll
get to that but there were some and i
want to compare here people so it's not
left versus right man it's about it's
about the you know the elites and the
well okay look
i understand that however
the elites the people who want to
maintain power within the elite
are the left they they require
the maintenance of power right you now i
understand you have some con republicans
who are not obviously conservative but
the fact is the guy you want
in charge of running the country the guy
who doesn't need the job and the guy
doesn't really want the job you have
nothing but career politicians in the
left some people say it's not left
versus right but it's elite versus the
general population well guess what
there's no one more elite than leftist
democrats than people in the hollywood
entertainment elite establishment than
people who have been tenured in
educational institutions for decades
despite sucking at their job so you do
need to recognize that what creates a
system of elite is a bureaucracy a
bureaucracy which cannot be penetrated
and that's the goal of the left that's
the goal of the marxist that's the goal
of the communists like sotomayor so
this is so important it's just how
how blatantly they lie and i think now
we're seeing um this sort of delayed
effect
where
at one point people like uh sotomayor
people like briar could get away with
these lies and i don't mean miss
speaking i mean proactive lies that
you'll hear
because they wouldn't be called on it
and now i think that's why they're
calling for the banning of programs like
this yeah because they still don't want
to be called on it so while they were
talking about osha's authority and while
they were talking about uh
omnicore kron you're going to screw me
up with that there dave you and your you
and your robocop references well
omnicorp just makes more sense because
we can get away with saying whatever we
want about it
with nuke so right
um they accuse both sides accuse the
other side of fear-mongering that's true
it happens to a degree
i don't even think it's close as it
relates to covid you have one side
saying look move on with your life
at some point the choice is yours these
are the risks this these are the rewards
if you want to be vaccinated if you
don't want to be vaccinated these are
the death rates these are the infection
rates and one side is saying shut
everything down stop your life
quarantine at home indefinitely and
certainly the only difference the only
difference between the united states
democrats and what is happening in
australia and what has happened in the
uk what has happened across europe is
democrats don't have unfettered power
yet let me ask you this genuinely and
the more comments the better here with
our first show back genuine question do
you think if the sotomayors if the
pelosi's if the aocs of the world if the
biden if the uh the former vice
president biden if kamal harris's of the
world had unfettered power
if they completely did away with checks
and balances do you think for one second
that they wouldn't act locked down
similar to what you see in australia you
saw across europe do you honestly doubt
that for a second that's why they want
to get rid of things like the filibuster
that's why they want to make it easier
to fundamentally transform america
without the gridlock that the ignorant
american [ __ ] is about you know i wish
we could get something done in
washington no you don't that's like
wishing that a bunch of retards could
get their hands on guns
you don't do that no you don't want them
to you want to keep the guns away from
them i've met a few people yeah well you
know it's they're on the spectrum yeah
are we still talking about uh pelosi
we're talking about oh sorry but the
point here is you want to see the
gridlock because the gridlock keeps us
from being australia the gridlock keeps
us from being europe um no i got that
there david yeah i'm saying she's very
smart yeah we should all listen to her
yeah her boyfriend's feet we all wanna
and she in no way has crazy eyes no and
i think it's what do you mean crazy eyes
i'm doing my best she doesn't look like
a horse that drank from a dirty trough
to get covered no no absolutely i hope
she's okay every time i see her uh an
instagram live stream i don't think it's
a mr ed rerun no i don't at all gorgeous
woman wilbur so
let's go to the first claim from
sotomayor um where she she actually said
this
this sequence of words in this phrase
that you are about to hear knowing that
we would all hear it and it was going to
be broadcast hundreds of thousands of
kids in the hospital
with uh with covet here you go we have
over a hundred thousand children which
we've never had before in in serious
condition
and uh many on ventilators
i'm sorry what yeah none of those things
are true no not only other things not
true they're not even close to the
ballpark of true hey look look several
blocks behind you at that ballpark
behind that
is something that resembles truth
okay
unbelievable i'm really tired of them
using kids too as well at this point
saying that that's what it is because
they tried in the beginning where they
were like oh well it actually doesn't
affect you and they're slowly trying to
develop variants that supposedly kill
kids yeah yeah it's really getting to be
a bit too much do you know how many uh
miners have been admitted to hospitals
uh between march 2020 and june 2021. so
christine was dead so not that many so
not as many well no i said hospitals not
sex oh i'm sorry yeah yeah yeah though
he does have shower rooms in every house
i just thought the golden globes
happened and nobody knew don't trust
saint epstein's children's hospital
i don't care how many kids with progeria
sitting with jennifer aniston say it's
great and still don't send them to saint
pepsi go there ronald
look um
how many would you think children she
said a hundred thousand you would think
like when you're talking about fact
checking someone is in the supreme court
right because people always say these
are the experts you should trust the
experts okay how close do you think she
got it
the number between march 2020 and june
2021
3100 ah 3 194 total miners admitted to
hospitals wow
in that period of time and by the way
that number includes people who are
admitted for other reasons and just
happened to test positive for covid
which if you go back to change my mind
regarding covet numbers being inflated
at two years ago and everyone said i was
crazy guess who's saying that now fouchy
i think it's important that we
distinguish between people who are
admitted for covid
versus people who are in the hospital
and already have coveted oh is that a
fact [ __ ] because i've been saying
that for years remember the guy who died
in the motorcycle accident who then
tested positive for covid remember the
guy in michigan who blew his own head
off and survived somehow on an iron lung
in the hospital and contracted covet
they were listed as covet deaths all
references available at
lyderthreider.com yes but we can't yeah
we can't let them have this by the way
the only reason that they're doing that
now is because in the past they could
blame donald trump for all these bad
cases right they had no incentive to
actually tell you what real numbers were
now they're trying to run cover for joe
biden right because everybody is laying
this at his feet like you haven't
controlled it this is going to cost you
the elections in the midterms and the
presidency potentially in two and a half
years right she was only off by ninety
seven percent right right right i think
that's something that we need to credit
her look look look look you can be great
at only a few things in life she's a
judge yeah you can't be bothered with
reading news well look when you're
taking the swings that big you're gonna
have some misses yeah 97 out of 100.
yeah there's nothing wrong with that no
can you imagine being the lawyer they're
going uh um
with with i'll do oh how do i say this
the kid who breaks right to give you an
idea her batting average is worse than
the kid who babe ruth pointed for who
was dying in the hospital bed if that
kid went up to bat in place of babe ruth
he would have a better batting average
than sotomayor with her prediction he
just had to get hit by the ball which i
think would be pretty right yes exactly
yeah i mean the head was swollen yes it
would have been easy just lean into it
yeah it looks like he's walking well
he's wheeling first well that was by the
way
charlie brown you know they're like
they're like on the ninth charlie brown
it's like lassie because it's progeria
it's not a long lifespan no not a long
no no so sotomayer also claimed here's
another claim that uh omnicron and she
said this again this is the supreme
court justice
when people say what did i say omnicron
i love it i love how much
[Laughter]
we made it for people who are just
tuning in we made a joke about omnicore
which is a robocop reference right here
and now in my head here i'll zip up my
jacket okay i don't think that's gonna i
don't think it's gonna help i don't
think it'll make that much of a
difference at this juncture it looks so
fat in this chair i like the look lovely
like the gesture i'll lean in so the ohm
i can't the crap
just go with it the omicron on me if you
hear me say omnicron omnicore omicron
you know what i'm talking about the
sniffles
omnicorp will not get us in trouble no
they will not no no either way someone's
jumping out of window yeah because right
now you know somebody's watching this
just waiting to report us
um omnicore
the omnicore virus this is what
sotomayor said again knowing that this
would be broadcast to all but with no
concern that tells you the lack of any
fear of reprisal or accountability said
that it's as deadly and caused just as
much disease as
last year's delta variant did don't take
my word for it
that omicron
is as deadly
and causes as much serious disease in
the unvaccinated as delta did
the numbers look at the hospitalization
rates that are going on
so here's the thing she's saying look at
the numbers while really hoping that you
don't look at the numbers because
not even close
[Laughter]
not even close you didn't hit the fact
check i didn't really hear much about
delta well no delta was where it was way
more uh
the truth is from what we know now the
first wave was probably the most dealt
uh probably the most delta the first
first wave was probably the most
deadly still delta was uh more
contagious more communicable
remember i always said i bet you were
going to find out that it's probably
more communicable less lethal seems like
it might have been in comparison to the
alpha and now there is no doubt that
omicron omicron
omnicore is uh significantly more
transmissible and significantly less
deadly you can go back to shows that are
a year old two years older i said if you
understand how viruses mutate back when
we had dr peter mccullough on long
before he was on joe rogan's show and
i'm glad he's getting some shine now or
elsewhere long before he was appearing
everywhere else we talked about the the
tendency of of viruses to mutate and
they try to mutate so they can attach
themselves to more hosts in which case
it is not in their own self-interest to
be more lethal because they want as many
hosts as possible so
no it's not even close sotomayor is
wrong it's not nearly as deadly as the
delta variant there has been the biggest
spike in cases in history by the way the
two biggest spikes in cases in history
the three biggest spikes in history have
happened under former vice president joe
biden not donald j donald j trump or
devin though happened under joe biden
even though
he didn't create he didn't uh fast-track
the vaccines that was donald trump and
then joe biden said this is a part of
our strategy more people vaccinated the
biggest spikes ever have occurred under
former vice president joe biden the
biggest single spike ever occurred with
the omicron variant and the deaths have
not spiked proportionally with
not even close as they did with delta
remember at one point where you would be
removed if you said about the original
variant like when they were saying hey
the death rate could be anywhere from
two to seven percent the imperial
college of london yeah and if you said
back then like actually i think the
death rate will if people projected some
people did we would never predict this
say i think it could eventually be more
comparable to the flu in death rate than
a seven percent death rate right you
know what i mean and now we know it's
like a 0.3 death rate the original one
or 0.1 now it's significantly lower with
the omicron variant i don't know what's
bandworthy i don't know which doctors
are no longer allowed on youtube
facebook twitter but apparently you
don't need to hear from a diverse voice
a diverse group of voices in the uh the
medical community you just need to
listen to sotomayor who said that a
hundred thousand children are in
hospitals on ventilators because of
omicron and it's more deadly than delta
there you go follow the science sorry i
mispronounced a crazy [ __ ] yeah
actually and and just so
the reason this matters this is the
person who will cast their vote on the
decision if you can be mandated to get a
vaccine that's what they're talking
about in this case just just think about
that what kind of data are they pulling
from to make the decision that yes we
have to mandate a vaccine for everybody
at a company with over 100 employees
right that should scare the hell out of
you well and also you know even
listening to that doctrine everything
you get
three grand if a patient dies allegedly
i'll just say so we don't get thrown off
of here but part of it is
like if
i don't know it just pisses me off yeah
i have like nine thoughts going through
my head right now and i'm trying to pick
one but yeah hospitals do get money off
of it yeah and right now with omnicron
after being you know wished by the white
house that everyone dies who's unvaxxed
before the holidays yeah for the winter
is coming yes
i'm a little yeah it's a little pissed
i'm a little pissed off by the way if
you put that uh if you put that jon snow
uh you know fur cloak on fouchy he just
turns into cousin it is it true yeah
he's a handsome man
i don't think people are gonna listen to
him after he loses his looks i tweeted
[Laughter]
he's just such i think it's his charisma
yeah that is the reason why we're all
listening to him right yeah pitching his
athletic ability is outstanding i don't
know if it's his facts his charisma or
his looks but fauci is definitely look i
don't know if i'm of course i can say
this okay we now have a variant
omicron okay yeah we have a variant
which is significantly more
transmissible okay communicable whatever
term you want to use it has outcompeted
delta and the original variant it is the
primary variant right it has overtaken
all the other variants if you're
catching uh covet now you're very likely
catching omicron okay so now it's taken
over all the more deadly forms of kovid
it's become the form of covid that
everyone catches and the vast majority
of people have very little symptoms
according to the cdc according to them
not us you could argue that omicron is
responsible for reducing deaths more
than the vaccines
that's that's that's theoretically
possible theoretically argument possible
yes we'll have to double check with uh
dr sotomayor well well only time will
tell yes and uh then we also have
justice breyer i'm a hoggins dawes guy
wow this that there were
750 million new cases and we said this
last week yesterday listen i asked
i mean you know 750 million new cases
yesterday
yeah or close to that well uh or uh not
even remotely close to that
mr breyer in the same sense that it's a
number yeah and this same set's like
well they're both numbers right come on
right
numbers guys right it's a one it's one
seven hundred fifty million they're both
numbers so
uh let me give you an idea as to just
how wrong that is 750 million in one day
that would be one in 10 people on earth
so that would mean that just the day
before he spoke
every single person who lives in japan
north korea south korea england france
uzbekistan saudi arabia kenya nigeria
and brazil would have had to catch
omicron in one day briar you're full of
it that's a fact check that check
okay
the entire population of europe now you
can say that he misspoke but again when
you take this the totality of the
sotomayor well when the other side gets
banned from every single platform for
miss speaking right yes that's quite
fair right well when we got uh suspended
from youtube for saying that uh uh you
know that it was less uh at one point
someone said
someone pointed at one point on this
show to the cdc sheet yeah that showed
that there were more uh flu deaths in
children at that point yeah then kovid
well yeah uh so you know i don't have a
lot of grace
no i could still point at certain pieces
of paper i won't name which ones on the
cdc website you can do your own research
yeah yeah yeah i just i don't want to
get in trouble again and by the way a
piece of used toilet paper is more
useful research for you than whatever
sotomayor is using
they call the constitution right ah yes
i have the face of mary in my with wipe
so
awful so uh deeply spiritual let's
compare this with the media and people
on twitter and the blue checkmark
brigade they were furious and because we
want to be i want to look at both sides
here you tell me what severity uh what
degree of severity you see with the lies
gorsuch
uh neil gorsuch you know the one who was
appointed under donald trump who's also
been disappointing to me in a lot of
ways
he said
that uh well what the left tried to
claim he said
still wouldn't have been wrong they
tried to claim that he said hundreds of
thousands of people die each year from
the flu
uh okay but it's pretty clear if you
listen to what he's saying hundreds or
thousands but either way it's still not
even in the same ballpark as sotomayor
and breyer listen to what justice neil
gorsuch said the flu kills
i believe hundreds of thousands of
people every year
osha's never purported to regulate on
that basis what do we make of that when
we're thinking about what qualifies as a
major question and what doesn't right
okay so now to be clear the supreme
court corrected the transcript from
hundreds of thousands to hundreds comma
thousands so he was saying the flu kills
hundreds uh or thousands and by the way
i think he would have been more accurate
if he would have said hundreds of
thousands let me explain to you why
because uh the world health organization
said that about 650 000 people die of
the flu each year oh yeah wow so yeah no
it was obviously a pause the rest of
this how do you okay sotomayor 100 000
kids what did you mean to say yeah
something close i mean it was i meant to
say that
i like to lie
he meant to say hundreds of thousands
that's why he ended with i think no no
no neil gorsuch doesn't tell the truth i
uh uh i know that everyone has omicron i
found or they i found it in my salad
lucy i was playing cards on the boat i
was not with another woman i went to
jail
that you would say i did it was good by
the way yeah that won the golden globe
did you know the golden globes happened
uh this last week and it was watched by
quite literally the singular thousands
ah wow that's weird we don't want to see
uh leftists pat themselves on the back
and give each other giant golden
trophies for pretending to be the people
we liked without ricky gervais it
doesn't work i would love to see ricky
gervais just host like uh ever like a
jerry telethon yeah he was the best of
course i would have had him come out
here read these cards but they can't
read i don't care
the kids are gonna die anyway comedy
yeah you brought up i've seen he's like
what he's your friend he's your friend
i don't care you flew on his plane had
sex with children what so none of you
have the right to tell anybody how to
live their life exactly
so this didn't stop though gorsuch when
he said that this didn't stop uh uh
what's going on what's going on right
now is this is this live hold on a
second before i go back to gorsuch this
is rand paul look he tried to comb his
hair he's been watching the show um
what is he saying what is he bitching
about i think he curled it
the
arrogance that justifies in his mind
using government resources to smear
and to destroy the reputations of other
scientists who disagree with them in an
email exchange with dr collins you
conspire and i quote here directly from
the email
to create a quick and devastating
published takedown that's right that's a
horrible thing a prominent
epidemiologist from harvard
oxford and stanford yeah they're not
going to happen there's a lot of fringe
epidemiologists at
harvard oxford
in the email that they were from dr
collins and you you agree that they are
fringe and immediately there's this
takedown effort a published takedown
though you know doesn't exactly conjure
up the image of a dispassionate
scientist
instead of engaging them on the merits
you and dr collins sought to smear them
as fringe and take them down
and not in journals in lay press
this is not only antithetical to the
scientific method it's the epitome of
cheap politics and it's reprehensible dr
fauchim
do you really think it's appropriate to
use your 400 i want to see a thousand
dollars
that disagree with you
[Laughter]
the email you're referring to was an
email he's wearing rouge dr collins to
me i believe that's the wrong kind of
mask that you responded to and hurried
up and said i can do it i can do it we
got something in wired oh no i think in
usual fashion
senator you are distorting everything
about me did you ever object to dr
collins's characterization of them as
friends did you write back to dr collins
say no they're not fringe they're
esteemed scientists and it would be
beneath me i did not do that you
responded to him that you would do it
and you immediately got an article you
and your beauty little doll's eyes said
hey look shark's awesome
i didn't know he was the troll in
earnest stupid it's the same
no this wasn't the only time your desire
to take down those who disagree with you
didn't stop with harvard oxford and
stanford you conspired with peter dayzak
who you communicated with privately and
other members of the scientific
community that wrote opinion pieces for
nature now randomly all of them signed a
finish paper and let him hang himself
seventeen signed a paper that called it
conspiracy theory the idea that the
virus could have originated in the lab
do you think words like conspiracy
theory should be in a scientific paper
i never used that word when i was
referring to it you're distorting
virtually everything did you communicate
with the five scientists who wrote the
opinion piece in nature where they were
describing oh this there's no way this
could happen what's on the lab me what i
did you talk with any of those things
by the way control room find me a clip
of fouchy at any point in the last two
years saying that it did not originate
from a lab or it originated from nature
just get it to us for later in the show
because we all know he's lying we can
fact check him live here
going back to that original discussion
when i brought together
a group of people to look at every
possibility with an open mind so no you
didn't you said that it came from nature
and then when you were held to the fire
namely jon stewart you said oh the tides
are turning i better make it look like
i'm objective
i've been spending too much time in aids
bath houses
how about when they said don't do
lockdowns how did that work out people
and the purpose of the committee was to
try and get things out how we can help
to get the american public and you keep
coming back to personal attacks on me
that have absolutely no personality you
personally smeared and attacked
dissenting doctors that's what he's
bringing up and this is a guy with a
perpetual victim complex look let me
just re unfortunately rand paul isn't
the best who is the guy you had on the
show though real quick uh peter
mccullough yeah yeah he had him smeared
and to the point where he said that you
weren't a harvard graduate yeah he's
like no dr peter mccullough his medical
license was revoked i think isn't he
didn't he go to bed uh before christmas
they tried to revoke they tried to know
that before christmas
i will say this rand paul senator take a
lot of these folks they don't ask
questions the way that i think that they
need to ask questions here's how it
needs to be framed in okay and this is
how you know that
i was about to say rand fauci oh man
that would be a weird hybrid
doc
rand paul he drinks a serum turns into
fauci well i think i'm going to go get
some tasty ways
use me like a towel rack so
you have two more wishes yes
and by the way the rules say you can
wish for more wishes
so
here's here's what he uh uh was asking
and this shows you the perpetual victim
complex and it's an actual psychological
condition that fauci has
rand paul brings up the fact that dr
fouching people in the medical
establishment people in the medical
establishment i mean people who are
unelected advisors people who are
unelected to the most highly paid and
highly influential positions of
government when we talk about the swamp
we're not just talking about senators
we're not just talking about congressmen
and congresswomen or congress zs because
these people can eventually be voted out
regardless of how you feel about
campaign finance law someone like fauci
has never had to earn a vote and a lot
of these people on these panels have
never had to earn a vote and they want
to protect their job security and so
what do they do they smeared the names
and the reputations of
scientists doctors from harvard from
stanford from oxford i believe are the
ones that he just named so this was
brought up the emails were brought up
from rand paul by the way these people
were right these other doctors from
these esteemed uh medical schools at the
very least maybe you say i'm an oxford
guy harvard let's just say it's top 10
and say it's enough you know most of the
doctors have probably seen it i don't
know a patient in the last 40 years
unlike a dr fauci who spends all his
time in russian bath houses being hit
with reeds so the point is this is
brought up
he's saying look look your folks
basically mounted an attack campaign
against these people for speaking out uh
against some of the information that you
were spreading and uh
do you have any regrets about it do you
think that that was appropriate to do do
you think that's part of the scientific
process and fauci goes no what you're
doing is attacking me no he's discussing
the fact that you and your unelected
colleagues attack
everybody including doctors we've had on
this show you know who else is unelected
you know who else isn't elected susan
wojcicki you
mark zuckerberg you know else unelected
whoever replaced jack dorsey i don't
remember the name right now it sounds
like vagina something like that i have
no idea the point is this these people
are unelected and they have determined
because they get on a speed dial without
you they talk about talking with fauci
they say oh you know what no you can't
actually say that uh the flu is more
deadly uh to to children oh no you know
what you can't actually say that the
death rates are lower oh you know what
you can't and these are unelected people
in positions of power greater than the
president of the united states these are
people who are unelected in positions of
power greater
than the emperor of rome
think of that for a second and fauci
makes it why are you attacking me well
one you're a dick and it's fun two you
were wrong and you're lying that's all
he ever does is sit there and [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] about how he's being
attacked he won't answer a single
question so you know what guys in the
control you you can watch it send me if
he says anything useful i'm willing to
bet this is just a roundabout situation
it's gonna be going round and round and
then eventually lady lane will pop up
and say why is fouchy over here like
let's give that a little
imagination well the fact that he's a
video too
from uh abc news from may of 2020 where
they're quoting a national geographic
article where fouchy made some claims oh
all right well let's watch this in real
time that's the beauty of doing the live
show the downside is sometimes they
strike us the plus side is we get to do
this this morning dr anthony fauci is
shooting down theories that the
coronavirus was man-made he tells
nationals
everything about the stepwise evolution
over time strongly indicates that this
virus evolved in nature and then jump
species
balchi
and he also said there was no scientific
evidence that it came from a lab that's
odd so his really weird uh defense where
he's sweating just now is a lie right no
no no it was a personal attack it wasn't
a professional critique oh right right
sorry doc on him yeah sorry dr fauci
we're going to have to uh take off these
electrodes did i fail the lie detector
test we actually can't get a reading
because of uh how uh sweaty you are
there's so much
he did
i saw him holding this up uh on my
screen over here he did just claim that
rand paul's website encouraged people to
try and kill him because it said fire dr
fauci is that why he oh yeah is that the
picture
yeah he held up a picture that said fire
dr fauci yeah oh my god that's the best
not rain ever she held that up and said
right now no i think i think fauci held
up the photo
yeah people need to pull and just make
that yeah they need to breathe just make
it look fire dr fauci the man just put
it up yeah
i think you can see
that uh rand paul if you go on his
website attempted to gang rape me uh i
rest my case
if you can see there's the penis and
testicles and i believe that you know
what's being inferred and i would like
him to be taken to the gulags do we have
gulags yet sorry that's in a couple of
weeks what am i saying why am i talking
no i talk too much i thought you hold up
a picture like that see the balls are on
my chin do you see it you see hold on
let me put my mask back on oh i got this
one that doesn't work oh no and hold on
no that's a picture of uh while i'm
sleeping uh donald trump uh
he's tea bagging me if you if you guys
want that's kamala harris teabagging me
this these are all tea bags i'll get
back to you with the threat i drew most
of these
i uh i dabble in erotica along with
baseball cards yeah yeah animation
erotica oh boy
if you guys want to see the rest of the
clip too uh mission control just said i
cut it a little short he goes on to talk
about how it didn't come from a lab oh
okay great yeah let's watch the rest of
this so that i can uh well you know what
this one's not loaded but i'll blow my
brains out after
he added he does not believe another
theory that the virus occurred naturally
but was accidentally released into the
public from a lab in china telling nat
geo that means it was in the wild to
begin with that's why i don't get what
they're talking about
really
you're a doctor sir of course we
remember all of this because the
country's been locked up for almost
three years right yeah you remember him
saying that he didn't think that it came
from a lab right i remember him being
like i may have funded it yeah i didn't
fund it
oh you didn't fund the lab i'm sorry did
i say i didn't i meant yes i absolutely
funded it yes
okay let's be honest carried the virus
out yes
i actually carried the virus
in a butterfly jar and i poked holes in
it because i i wanted it to breathe and
i put in some alfalfa sprouts and then i
released it into the wild hoping that uh
if nature was kind it would take it in
as one of its own instead it just i mean
i really made an error in judgment uh
forgive me sorry i forgot you never made
a mistake there was a local and he
looked like he might do karate on me so
i threw the jar at him and all of a
sudden everybody got the sneezes and
then we broke bats together and engaged
in fellowship
that's where he went wrong
what a worthless doctor was it ozzy
osbourne that's who it was
me and ozzy broke bits yes i snorted
ants for breakfast yes absolutely
okay uh now look anyway the the the
problem with the gorsek thing i was just
talking about this is they tried to say
that he said hundreds of thousands of
people die from the you know look
hundreds of thousands of people do die
from the flu every single year but
here's what i wanted to get to as well
is
the right should hold the right
accountable
and they do yeah now not as well as as
uh i would like to see them do it for
example right now i don't think that was
the best line of questioning from uh
senator rand paul and i like senator
rand paul yeah even though he's bristly
that being said
let's look at these lies that we just
went through from sotomayor and breyer
and see how they were treated on cnn by
jake tapper who is seen as my god the
epitome of actual journal i threw up in
my mouth a little bit
and we'll compare it to what tucker
carlson did with senator ted cruz
rightfully so i want you what matters is
not just which side is right here's the
thing before you get to which side is
right and there is a right side and a
wrong side i don't shy away from this
idea of partisan politics doesn't mean
that the right is correct on everything
what the left is well the left is pretty
much wrong on everything but the right
isn't correct on everything yeah that
being said there is a right and a wrong
and they do tend to line they do tend to
fall on one side of the political line
at this point so before you get to that
though
the only way you determine what is right
is what is through a system of
accountability through a meeting of the
minds through diverse
voices
voices not skin color not penis vagina
or uh you know split five guys hot dog
my point is if you have a diverse set of
opinions calling each other out
that's how you determine what is correct
let's see
how they hold sotomayor's feet to the
fire on cnn with jake tapper and joan i
heard some assertions made by the
supreme court justices today that were
simply
false one example justice sotomayor said
quote we have over 100 000 children
which we've never had before in in
serious condition and many on
ventilators that that's just not true
okay there are fewer than 5 000 miners
hospitalized with code right now seen
there on the right we're showing the
figures not a hundred thousand and that
includes miners who were admitted
because of covid and ones who tested
positive but had been hospitalized for
other reasons
well there were a lot of facts and
figures thrown out from uh justices
across the spectrum that uh some of them
certainly raised questions from from
people who really know their stuff on
this issue everyone knows that
vaccinations work everyone knows that
that's what saves lives but her
colleagues on the right wing were coming
at it from a very different direction uh
and as you probably know justice
sotomayor actually wasn't in the room
she was because she has diabetes she was
listening to the arguments and asking
questions from her chambers yeah i mean
facts are important though
diabetes i don't give a rat's ass if she
has a fake leg
think about that she was talking beyond
the court well stop
your job is to be a jedi you're in the
court she was talking to me on the court
because uh uh i can think of the victim
complex that you see from people on the
left think of the excuses there she was
talking beyond the court that's not her
job and uh that's because the right was
going after really hard who cares if
they're correct it doesn't matter if
they're going after her hard also she
has diabetes and uh she's lonely she had
four cookies she could have said
anything yes yes
that's really not so much uh the result
of poor research as it is uh some craft
mac and cheese yes fauci had made some
stuff up in his tree for her yeah yes
well just just remember that pivot we'll
come back to it the pivot is well and
like i said we know that vaccines are
the best way to keep people that's
exactly what they pivoted to each time
right that's what they said she just
said there we know vaccines are the best
way hold on a second wasn't it uh uh the
former australian uh prime minister
what's his name uh malcolm uh what was
it uh outcome in the middle i don't know
oh malcolm turnbull okay fully vaxxed
and boosted and i believe it was i
believe it was broadcast and this is
anecdotal but statistically this is also
reflected just caught covet now here's
the thing oh
people who are vaccine boosted are
getting omicron at one point you would
be fact checked remember if you said
that when you were vaccinated on social
media if you said even the vaccinated
can catch and transmit it you were fact
checked then they acknowledged okay you
can but it's not as likely and then it
was okay you can but you get milder
symptoms but here's the thing now with
omicron if you're vaccinated
you can get it even if you're vaccinated
and boosted we see it all the time okay
you have mild symptoms if you're not
vaccinated you can get it
and you have mild symptoms
you're still going to blame to something
there is no discernible difference
in contracting covet at this point if
your vac's boosted or run back it's like
well what's going to happen if your own
vex well i have mild symptoms what's
going to happen if you're facts mild
symptoms well geez that's a tough
decision
yeah that's so i get this thing in my
body that we don't know if it causes
myocardosis or you know problems with
menstruation what is it what's that
myocardial cardiac disease
i'm sorry i'm not a doctor yeah neither
are these people no but it's true at
least i got it closer than one hundred
thousand we got a closer than this lady
in the dame edna glasses oh that's true
but crying out loud do you think this
lady takes pride in looking like she
rolled out of the wrong side of the bed
what is with cnn and wacky glasses it's
like it just should be the wacky glasses
channel do you think their stylist just
says no no no no the the more disheveled
you look the more credibility you have
yes i want you to look like you are a
1950s secretary in a clown world yes but
i want you to look like the 1950s
secretary who none of the executives
wanted to sleep with no the one they had
to hire right because she lost her
husband the one who was hired by the
executive's wife ah yeah yeah
hey by the way you're hiring selma damn
it i want to hire sandy it's selma you
keep leaving your socks stirrups in
hotel rooms
i know what you're doing
i just want to make sure we're talking
about the same australia that just had a
four day like lockdown and if you
weren't vaccinated you couldn't leave to
go to work yeah penal colony of rapists
and murderers yeah yeah yeah at that
place okay so uh let's compare this to
you just saw what they did there where
they allowed her to get away with all of
these excuses on sotomayor yeah let's
compare this to tucker carlson holding
senator ted cruz's feet to the fire over
the fact that ted cruz senator ted cruz
did very disappointingly
refer to uh
many of the protesters on january 6th as
terrorists now i do in his defense i
think he was meaning to say the people
who breached the capital right uh but
doesn't matter it still doesn't make
these people terrorists right uh here is
an actual interview holding someone's
feet to the fire so i guess what i mean
there are a lot of dumb people in the
congress you're not one of them and
you're smarter than i am uh and you
never use words
carelessly um and yet you called this a
terror attack when by no definition was
it a terror attack that's a lie it was
sloppy and it was frankly dumb and i
don't buy that whoa whoa whoa whoa i
don't buy that front look i've known you
a long time since before you went to the
senate you're a supreme court contender
you take words as seriously as any man
who's ever served in the senate and
every word you repeated that phrase i do
not believe that you use that
accidentally i just don't
but that person's still not a terrorist
how many people have been charged with
terrorism on january 6th like why'd you
use that word you're playing into the
other side's
characterization that is joe kent just
explained allows them to define an
entire population as foreign combatants
and you know that so why'd you do it so
who's ray epps by the way since you are
a senator like he and this other guy are
clearly encouraging the crowd
to commit crime tell him you have
diabetes neither one has been arrested
or charged
what is that
how it would have been great like you
know tucker
i had low blood sugar
i had diabetes because again i
pronounced it like wilfred brimming yeah
yeah i needed a built bar tucker yeah
that's really what i needed yeah i just
needed one right there they're not even
they're not even uh sponsored today but
go to built.com yeah see that little
extra problem hey i did i lost some
weight you did i noticed part of it
was the billboard just replaced my
sweets with them built bars started
eating the birthday cake yeah you know
because i don't want to be like
sotomayor with the diabetes nope
that's what she needs there i bet you if
she'd had a built bar instead of a
little debbie she wouldn't have been off
by 97 300.
just filled with brain fog and not
enough yes exactly she's like i am so
i'm sorry i have a long term coverage in
my in my brain i don't know why she
sounds like anna navarro uh no you don't
you're just dumb works she looks like
delta burke if she was hispanic yes
uh are you about to say something i i
was going to ask if you wanted to see
the kind of funny exchange between fauci
and rand paul you know what let's do
that before we leave because i'm going
to go to the project very to us and gain
a function and i'm sure that'll probably
tie back oh yeah that will so uh by the
way everyone out there uh again smash
everyone watching right now smash the
like button right now if you're on
youtube smash the like button this is
our first day back after being banned
and uh when youtube suspends you that
really hurts you in the algorithm so
smash the like button and when this
video is done being broadcast live just
ask that you leave a comment we discuss
things with you dave is in there all the
time uh just don't
don't let him send you direct messages
yes
well it's what i do sweet
cherrydetroitpd69
yahoo.com is not
the email that you want to see that's
just one of those but you've grown the
list quite a bit i saw you were renting
it out to don jr that's correct wow huh
so and hunter i don't discriminate
it was just selling gouda he destroyed
it so uh all right so but we're going to
move on here we have a few things we'll
punt new york to tomorrow because it's a
hell hole surprise but what's going on
right now in international news uh
kazakhstan right uh obviously um
there's been some violent unrest gerald
why don't you explain it to people who
don't know because this is a subject i
know that for americans is often very
boring uh and the reason for that is
because you know uh most of the world
doesn't care about kazakhstan and it's
unfortunate but it's because in the
realm of human history they've been
inconsequential gerald your ball uh a
little bit right so i think one of the
reasons that this matters is because of
what's going on in ukraine as well what
happened with crimea so there's there's
a whole lot that's that's really
happening right now but in kazakhstan
they basically had an issue with fuel
prices going up that was the initial
kind of protest reason right so they
ended a cap on fuel prices january and
these guys by the way it's an it's an
oil-rich nation so they shouldn't
necessarily have any problems with this
they have a lot of oil they do they have
plenty of oil but it was more about some
of the social issues that they're facing
as well so it started with gas it was
all about locked very social yes very
bad economy right but it's also about
yeah that's putin puppet leader who is
is essentially siding with russia yes
right so this is good for you how are
you excited about all that i got match
okay so 164 people were killed when he
basically ordered i can't yeah
164 people killed 8 000 people arrested
they called in russian troops to help
put this down now the only way that they
can do that is to say that outside
agitators russian troops cannot be
called in unless it is outside
influencers trying to kind of stir
things up and overrun the country so
they claimed that was what was going on
no it was just people protesting it was
just citizens protesting and saying look
you're a dictator essentially we don't
want you to jail people that you
disagree with and shoot people which is
what they've done they literally came
and that's like the blm protest going on
and donald trump saying national guard
gerald if you call the protest one more
time i will fire you where you don't
know i'm trying to use the elm riots blm
riots but that's like donald trump going
okay mostly peaceful riots shoot to kill
that's exactly what it'd be we're both
on very thinner
they were mostly peaceful right okay
okay it would be like turning the hell's
angels loose on the blm riots they do
rides for charity
well now they've they've reformed a
little bit yeah all right so here's why
you need to understand that this is
important
this is like the reconstituting of that
soviet bloc right this is basically
russia putting its of course yeah
putting power back out into these places
saying we're going to take over ukraine
we're going to take over these other
places now they don't have to physically
take over cops they just have to have
their guy in control that's it right
same kind of thing is happening here so
they're supposed to leave okay
everything's peaceful now they're
supposed to leave and this president is
supposed to reform a little bit um but
we'll see he tends to say that and not
actually do anything isn't it
interesting that uh you know for all of
the uh talk about donald trump and
russia yeah he kind of behaved pretty
well under those uh few years he did
danger
no didn't something happen with barack
obama in the ukraine yeah they took
something part of the country
something something georgia crimea
georgia there was something like that
and then we had we had what what would
you say about somewhere an estimate of
about uh maybe three three four years of
peace uh something like that something
like that i don't know like another
presidency term yeah something yeah and
now there it's like what are the chances
that they were like oh we were [ __ ]
i forgot to be an [ __ ] for about four
years
i just remembered i'm really good at it
yep
so i have decided to go back you know to
go back to my roots of s holistan
it's like you know you see rocky 3
what's happened is i train
in [ __ ] gym and i have eye of tiger
and hunger and then i reach point in
silk sheets where i say i don't need to
be [ __ ] anymore but then i wake up
one day and say i am no longer me you're
italian man with policy face stop cold
war yes yes
and now you have a demented circus
monkey who doesn't know uh where russia
is on map
he plays accordion quite well yes i
actually told him we were taking no land
and actually shrinking our borders by
tricking him in sending him board game
risk and used marker
so he gave us everything yes yes
you always start with australia i didn't
even ask for italy but i think so
um this is actually what's been going on
over uh kazakhstan last week and for
people who missed it a montage
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
how many of them do you think are drunk
oh yeah
[Music]
so much vodka
geez
well look serious hey at least what's
going on there is nothing compared to
what um you know we all know yeah uh
worse than pearl harbor a real
insurrection looks like
this
[Music]
in the capitol this is our house
how drunk do you think they are
you know
it was chilly
this is roughly the same yeah it's the
same thing film you've ever made in your
life
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody this must be peaceful this has
to be peaceful
that guy's worst crime is just dressing
like an idiot right wait what why did
they do this
why
in in kazakhstan why did i was because
it's because the uh gas prices
were too high dave what's going on why
are you nervous nothing just don't look
at cnn what's happening what's happening
on cnn right at all what is it
this is cnn breaking news
[Applause]
beyond
this is cnn breaking news
dave i've told you don't ever
who went over this don't start coos no
in foreign countries it was self-defense
no it was not that's that's not true and
you swore in another language i said
well i happen to know the language but
it wasn't to start the whole riot well
thank you but it sure did no sorry
i won't do it again
i'm probably going to do it this week
yeah i know look 838 a gallon i might
just don't do it on the clock
nobody was hurt except for some people
337 some except for some uh kazakhstani
oil wrestlers i like how this is
happening over there for real though and
here we're just like yeah just keep
banging us in the ass yes
that's fine we're just going to keep
rolling over for everybody else
in the bath house yeah yeah but
seriously like we're
that's what our gas prices have
quadrupled right and then they they're
like two dollars yeah
seriously killing everybody just think
comparing to australia australia like
going to a quarantine camp well i guess
quarantine came for me whereas in
catholics i'm like hey mind your own
crypto while i bang your mom yeah their
gas prices literally doubled that was it
yeah and that they're like taking to the
streets yeah
half of them don't even have cars like
it's the principal i want to blow [ __ ]
up
that's how you be a country yeah i mean
seriously i'd say you should don't do a
violent uprising that's not what i'm
saying no of course not i'm just saying
you need to stop taking it from behind
and just start yeah look here's the
beauty when people try and say oh the
right one's a civil war look long before
you ever get to the point of a civil war
uh how about this
go out
just go eat out yeah let's go outside
and let somebody give you crap and be
like i don't really care just
don't be afraid and live at home and
play by the rules
they can't chase you
like just that's what you start with you
just start not giving a rat's ass and
living your life that's what the red
states have done hey blue states
take notice take some notes well they
have aoc traveled down to a red state
for vacation got off she got omicron at
a drag party
yeah she she avoided it because she was
double vaccinated but it didn't take
into account making out with rupaul
well there was a story about people in
antarctica half of a research team
completely isolated from the rest of the
world got covered okay scoop can we all
just i know i shouldn't have touched
amazon prime package yes
she can't just say that it's that it's
fine that she was there because there's
no mandate it's like you enforce the man
mandates that's you showing that you
don't believe what you say right that's
what's important about seeing and you
have horrible taste in men yeah well
well
everybody wants to have sex with me and
they have a foot fetish for him it's
like what is wrong with you right yeah
you're an adult they have a foot fetish
for him but he has a face for a foot and
they have a foot for a face yeah that's
right so
i don't know why it's kazakhstan he
insulted aoc yeah i didn't know what the
accident is it's the kazakhstani jeff
ross roaster of the aoc hey i tried to
look alc in the eyes but one went
running away
i asked her if she wore a mask in front
and she said nay she said
she said
a stupid horse yes i asked her should i
bring flowers she said flowers how about
block of salt
if she breaks leg let's make sure this
she don't race no more yes the best part
about going
on date with aoc is that i get to have
dinner and win kentucky darby
[Laughter]
i want to place 50 new snagit this is
our currency on llc please
i don't have to buy her flowers when
she's already wearing wreath of them
around neck this is true i just have to
find time when she doesn't have drag
queen attached to sucking her face
this bruise from her kick yes
by that i mean headbutt
if they just started breaking out and
dancing in the protest oh it's dancing
during vodka
totally fine
she says she is worried about having
children because of climate change i
tell her do not worry because you're so
ugly you are barren
that's how it works you took the vaccine
so your period stuff
you are no longer a woman so i guess you
can now drive subaru yes aoc dead womb
oh boy
this is kazakhstani
insult comic
boy no one here believes this
he's bumping mikes but i'm not going to
say a slurphoration no we will not say
that
and by the way
speaking of bumping aoc was bumping
uglies with drag cream and i could not
pick out who was real lady
they both have same size penis yes
big horse penis so it's really more of a
weakness
we all have weenuses yeah we do it's
true big horse famous that's how she win
race so
big giant dragging behind her
she lady
listen of course this all means that we
are just wanting to date ayo
yes well it's because she's gorgeous i
can't take her out unless i tie cup to
back of her ass
she's
all right
she has feed trough
right here i tie it to her face so she
can eat the chili while i ride her yes
that's true and when i walk behind her i
have to put hand on ass to make sure she
not make for kick me
[Laughter]
also
she paralyzed christopher reeve so
she gets up she's just dragging a stage
goat
i didn't know she always had that behind
her hey did you see her cameo in new
episode of 1883 yes she was read by
faith hill so she pulled pumpkin um
what else uh i don't think we need to
talk about this anymore the russian
troops shut down the unrest they'll be
leaving in uh sure they will yeah and
just stay out of kazakhstan dave by the
way uh for those of you who are watching
here on youtube of course you can watch
on rumble audio a lot of people don't
know uh on apple on spotify on android
yeah because we never know when we get
the boot here on youtube you know we
were gone for a couple of weeks so
please we just don't want to lose touch
with you it happens monday through
thursday 10 a.m eastern uh we're
available on rumble we're of course
available on mud club but audio is
really important too and sometimes we
had some bonus content there um all
right we're going to end with this i
know we've gone a little late here it's
been fun today it has been fun
it didn't mean for me to be back yeah
i've had fun yeah well you know i really
i really like uh
i don't know i guess uh well we need to
find a name for a kazakhstani yeah yeah
we need a stinger yeah
the kazakhstani insult would be a good
reoccurring it would extend a rose comic
hey he could you know the next one is
project veritas the kazakhstani could
should he
do you think james o'keefe would have a
sense of humor about it i think so yeah
so this next person does great work in
exposing uh corruption of government
when he is not in ashley's chaps dancing
to oklahoma
aren't all chaps assless hey listen
who's the comedian you or me i don't go
to your job and slap penis out of your
face yes
it's a joke as all this time just like
as old as penis in your face
[Laughter]
one face that never have penis is uh aoc
it's repel it's penis gold like reverse
magnet
don't touch it
where did you learn the whisper a
helicopter covering riots downs down
below with people killing one another
yes i learned to whisper on helicopter
with brian williams yes
a very real story yes before hillary
clinton uh launched rocket
yes
so anyway uh a new military document
well we'll go back to this uh released
by project veritas james o'keefe they
really do some incredible work yeah uh
proves that fauci and the niad niaid
what is it national institute for
allergies and infectious diseases
something like that i don't know i knew
that they were funding
gain of function research in wuhan here
is and i recommend that you go watch of
course the full content project veritas
all references are available in the link
below uh and at lyderthrider.com here's
a clip project veritas has obtained a
separate report to the inspector general
of the department of defense written by
the u.s marine corps major joseph murphy
a former darpa fellow
major murphy makes claims in his report
to the inspector general that if true
could be damning to the official
narrative that has been played out to
the world over the past two years
major murphy's report states that eco
health alliance approached darpa in
march 2018
seeking funding to conduct gain of
funding research of bat born
coronaviruses darpa rejected the
proposal because the work was too
dangerous and could violate the gain of
function moratorium despite ecohealth's
position that it would not
according to the documents the niaid
under the direction of dr fauci did not
reject the proposal they went ahead with
the research at wuhan and several sites
across the u.s let me give you just a
few snapshots here because we have to go
to mug club
this is from major murphy the author of
the report um this is a government
agency by the way uh sars kovet ii is an
american created recumbent bat vaccine
or its precursor virus it was created by
an eco-health alliance program at the
wuhan institute of virology also it
should be noted that the report said
that ivermectin was quote identified as
curative in april 2020. the report
emphasized how hydroxychloroquine is
mentioned specifically by eco health in
their original proposal as a sars
coveted to uh aoc already have
ivermectin in her this true that's it
horsepower is officially horse drug now
yes that's it she's more of a she
prefers to take in paste form
but we have to hide it in cream cheese
yes otherwise she go like this and i
usually rub it on your gums so
peanut butter so the dog can eat
so this is what's important about this
and this is not definitive that
ivermectin works this is not i'm not
definitively saying that hydro
hydroxychloroquine is but what i'm
saying is this is something that was
specifically mentioned by ecohealth in
their proposal so when people acted like
donald trump or like anybody else just
took it out of thin air no this came
from what medical professionals people
who are following the science now
science changes what you can't do here's
here's how you kill science okay you
kill science in a few very very simple
steps
you kill science by blaming scientists
okay who are at the cusp of research
uh for being incorrect in by the way a
hypothesis people need to be able to
make a hypothesis and then test it okay
so you can't blame scientists for
creating a hypothesis saying hey we
think hydroxychloroquine might work
actually ivermectin is curative but
hypothesis with hydroxychloroquine if
you
fault scientists and you condemn them
for testing hypotheses guess what that's
bad for science and then on the flip
side if you allow scientists who have
tested their hypothesis who have come to
now a controlled conclusion and they are
wrong and you let them get off scot-free
you kill science that's exactly what
we're doing we're blaming the people who
are trying to test hypotheses early on
and we are letting people like fauci who
are verifiably wrong getting away
without any blame you couldn't pick a
more effective two-prong approach to
kill science uh basically darpa this is
the uh organization uh declined to fund
this research because it violated the
gain of function moratorium but fauci
and the national uh institute for uh
allergies and infectious diseases
granted the funding anyway and then
absolutely lied to congress about it and
i think we can end on by the way
everyone what
have you
where do you stand here right now on the
science where do you stand here i'm
gonna you know what i want to hear from
you guys how many of you have caught uh
omicron it went through my family we're
all fine uh
we're all fine we're all fine uh i want
to know how many of you out there got it
what your symptoms were like just
consider this a control group and again
if you are watching right now please
smash that like button here on youtube
um we have a clip that we're about to go
to and this clip is what there token
allen yeah just to be clear this is this
is what happened earlier when fauci was
talking about the death threat okay
thing it's pretty funny oh okay all
right well let's let's watch this
as some of you may know
just about three or four weeks ago on
december 21st
a person was arrested who was on their
way from sacramento to washington dc
that's a long time
and they asked the police asked him
where he was going
and he was going to washington dc
to kill dr fauci and they found in his
car an ar-15
and multiple magazines
of ammunition
because he thinks that maybe i'm killing
people so i asked myself
why would senator want to do this
so go to
rand paul website
and you see
fire dr fauci with a little box that
says contribute here you can do five
dollars ten dollars twenty dollars a
hundred dollars drive across state lines
with an ar-15 catastrophic epidemic for
your political gain so the only
political attack your colleagues and in
a politically reprehensible only things
i like the reputation okay you won't
defend it no don't argue it just simply
turn around continue
of people at stanford oxford at harvard
doctors who disagreed with you who by
the way are verifiably correct and he
goes you're just trying to attack me and
then there was a guy who wanted to kill
me hey guess what guess what [ __ ] tim
poole has been swatted more times than
you i am done youtube thank you but not
really we're gonna go to mug club we
have a tribute to bob saget youtube
everyone else smash the like button
comment we will see you tomorrow at 10
youtube piss off
you